ladies and gentlemen welcome let me make sure this
is all good we're all good we are all good welcome
everyone this is the puzzle rush week this is the
puzzle week we're going to do a lot of puzzles my
name is walter bick also known as bigfoot i'm the
chess.com esport producer for europe uh streamer
and all the other good stuff and we're here today
we're gonna have a very exciting week what's up
everyone what's up chess i see people already
in the twitch chat in the chest if we chat we're
going to have an amazing time today we're going
to have a lot of fun we're going to have look-ins
we're going to do some puzzles and there are a lot
of prizes to it so a lot of you probably wondering
what is going on what is what is this man doing
on my screen this man on your screen is going
to tell you what the format is today so we're
going to have a puzzle week ladies and gentlemen
and the puzzle week means that we're going to have
five days of puzzle action with a lot of prizes
for invited streamers let me add that real quick
for day one which is today which starts in four
hours four hours four minutes we have five minute
puzzle rush for three hours which means that for
three hours long we'll be here we'll look into
streamers invited streamers will be participating
they can win cash money each hour playing five
minute puzzle rush what those prices are i will
review those later so we'll look at that real
quick what is the man doing on the stream exactly
exactly day two will have survival modes where
environment streamers will pair up in teams of two
let's say hikaru and levi rosman for example and
are gonna try to reach the highest in survival
mode this is gonna be a very educational week
for everyone today um it's gonna be really
good on day three we'll have a puzzle battle so
it's not only the rush mode it's also the battle
mode where 16 invited streamers will play in a
bracket with three rounds of puzzle battle each
uh to see who will make it to the final and who
will get all the good stuff day four the same
as day one free middle puzzle rush for three
hours long where enviro streamers try to play
uh you know and get all the stacks the fame and
glory and all of the cash money which the most
important one and day five is the actual puzzle
battle championship on this day puzzle battle
is free for all just come users
if you don't have memberships
doesn't matter you can still play puzzle
battle for free which is going to be good
and it's going to be the championship where
they're going to play for big prizes now
the big thing what are the prizes i can hear you
say let me show you 23 000 in total for playing a
little bit of puzzles holy moly i can hear maurice
by the way maurice will be here tomorrow don't
worry about it and also for the other days who
also have danny in some of them so make sure you
stick around for the next days 23 000 that is no
joke yet uh for today the best overall score will
get a thousand second best overall score will get
750 and then the first second and third hour will
all receive 500 hondo's if you're first and
the best clip turtle 750 that's not too bad
who already invited streamers asks chess
queen in the chat uh you should have had a
invite for that if not my team is
listening in they will contact you
if that's the case so don't worry about that
chess queen um we'll try to get things rolling
these are the prizes this is what we have
right now um let me send a quick message
all right um so we're gonna we're gonna start
very soon ladies and gentlemen all if you have any
questions related to me while you're in twitch [
__ ] while in chesterfie chat let's make it going
what's up everyone daniel ranch the one and only
international master danny ranch is here as well
what's up man 37 months you beast i don't
think i have the alert so i'm just going to
make it like this uh thank you danny he's in here
as well danny will be here for day three and five
i believe for sure i'll make it work look smith
what's up everyone we're going to start really
soon we're actually going to start in a minute
um i'm not the only one ladies and gentlemen
not the only one gm hikaru nakamura is playing
as well and he's going to start his puzzle rush
run real soon so actually what we're going to
do right now is going to have a quick look in
to gm hicaro and see how he will be playing the
puzzlers thing right now that should be good
all right that should be good that should be a lot
better okay perfect yeah thank you to oscar with
the prime it's nerve with the prime they need
to adapt to paddle with the prime blow with the
prime crystal with the prime pull just there
with the prime nudity he carries coffee with
the prime trivia the prime rights gaming with
the tier one lala mix with the prime spark six
with the prime i need a bouncer for the seven
daniel wrench for the 28 raheem the dream for
the seven sushem for the four months thank you
i am oblivion for the three and cos get for
the three bucks okay i think it's time to start
right let's just make sure is it time to start
i think it's time to start right okay now
again you guys what i will say is that i
don't have to be super fast because remember
there's the the top scorer so as long as i
just go about this regular way then it's all
going to work out okay let's go checkmate okay
goal is to get 60 that's the goal if i can get 60
i'll be happy or not happy 60 i think is going to
be a winning score actually that's what i should
say um so let's go here in king b8 obviously time
to farm the best clips oh yeah yeah i better stop
i better stop the music for the clips then okay um
let's just take the queen let's take the knight
let's go check and work h8 and take the queen
uh takes takes i'm this one i'll probably i
won't set a high score but i just want to get
into the rhythm before i really go go nutso um
here here here that's good what is this this is
that's winning okay takes is good i don't
actually know what the feel of the streamers
is by the way just to be clear um so yeah let's
go here here let's go here collect the horse
collect that what is this we decided while
we're watching this this is a weird puzzle
and i really like the approach that he has here
i'm gonna take it slow you know i don't need to
get the first score right now we will get there
when we get there i'm going way too slow by the
way but whatever it's the first it's the first
first first go around so it's fine um actually
bae i'm just gonna i'm gonna leave walk my dog
it'll be back in three hours just put this one
check here here all right chad we're getting
i'm getting called out uh that i'll need to
play royalties to uh hikaru appearance so uh we
can't do that we're going to place themselves
well now we have a lot of streams so my job
here today is show you guys that puzzles are
very important for your own you know uh for
your own way to improve um i've been doing a
lot of puzzles lately it's really been helping
me uh to come to the point where i am today
and uh oh you like your design day listen man
we'll be doing a great thing we're gonna do a
great thing i'm gonna play some puzzle rush myself
as well because you know you guys also need to
deserve what it looks like for the normal one so
let's have a quick look chat let's have a look
how i fare in puzzle box you see the leaderboard
right now it's still a little bit empty so you
don't have to worry about it too much uh it will
get back soon how are you going to play some
possible chat um i'm white to move by the way
that helps because that is checkmate you know
you think that you think that i know that uh it's
a little bit different so we're going to have a
lot of streamers i saw danny nerdskis going and
amaya and a kremling we have a lot to look into
um so we will do that for now you know i'm just
going to show my own puzzle rescue you're like wow
this guy is great how can it be as great as this
guy you got to play puzzles yet that's the way to
improve well i mean not if you play that i mean
that was this um okay let's move forward uh we're
gonna play chess listen chad all right you guys
are putting a lot of pressure on me that's not
what i would like to see that's what you hate to
see in these games we're playing this password
right now uh so you guys can see how it works
how it rules and then we're going to look at some
streamers afterwards and i'm going to play the
format sporadically i'm going to see here we're
going to be here for three hours i'm gonna queen
this pawn with a check so we're gonna feel good
about it but that this is the thing that we
will be focusing on today ladies and gentlemen
puzzlers is proved by rating from 900 to 930
exactly and that's what you want to see it's
it's the best way to do it and i i just
love puzzles it makes me happy it makes
me a happy little kid um how do we do this
do we just move here look at that we defense
look at that chat it's that easy life can
be that easy do it take two pieces for it
uh where to move back this is
where the the [ __ ] starts yet
enough working for you today happy new
year daniel thank you for dropping by
absolutely uh we're gonna finish this run and then
we're gonna get back to the players don't worry
we'll compare this list i don't think we
have a full pair of this list right now but
what do i do here do we just take the pawn we do
just take the pawn well okay so is that easy um
but i will i will show everyone that is
participating so that will be good that's
not i should have defended it i hate to see
it you hate to see a chat you hate to see it
it's already we're already getting the blunders
that's where i like to see chad that is the good
stuff um all right we're gonna finish strong
here ladies and gentlemen the leaderboard is
not up to date right now because we're still
waiting for the possible scores to move in
but we will get there in another streamer
that we have going on that you might recognize
ladies and gentlemen is daniel neroditsky
let's have a quick look to see what he's
doing
okay take six oh okay okay let's go start again
i already knew once i got the first one let's say
i got the first one wrong okay i need i need to
be a little bit slower in these initial problems
look at the speed on this man look at the focus
what a beast
what a beast or not
okay mate probably this wins okay bishop b4
it's probably like chuck and chunk i think knight
if i wins the queen this one wins okay bishop c3
just fork him this is easy win okay
queen g6 and that h4 looks pretty good
oh i thought that was made for a second okay
check wait this is a trick maybe rookie one here
no ah you got one wrong puzzle say in other words
i gotta i'm gonna have to bleep that out next time
do you see this is the thing like when you play
puzzle rush in these kind of positions chad
when you get one wrong it's really hurt your
mental it really hurts mentally you can see you
could see him stopping he was going like a train
he was going through speech i mean maybe just 92.
and now he's uh i need to i'm going to be taking a
little bit longer like how am i going to approach
this it's very interesting to see i actually
really like that okay let's try thirty okay yeah
i'm back into it look at the jet you're probably
he's probably gonna have like 500 puzzles at the
end of the three hours i need to get at least
50 i mean that's sort of a baseline minimum goal
okay let's go by a simple rule i'm not
going to do it unless i see it even if
it takes me a minute unless i see the solution
i'm just not going to i'm not going to solve it
this is not memory i'm i'm never seen this before
in my life i'm solving it from the board that's
a really good point as well chet that is an
incredibly good as well because at this point
when you play a lot of puzzle rush you're going
to recognize teams or you're going to recognize
puzzles uh as well and i'm going to actually
give you a few tips on how to improve on your
puzzle rush very easy tips they come in i'll
show them real quick i'll show them in a moment
um but first we're going to look at daniel ditzki
and let's see which score he gets this time
yeah no i'm going to implement this because
the problem is i'll keep getting like one wrong
problem is like the threshold for when you see
it when you think you know it is always changing
okay i think it's an under promotion
yeah it definitely isn't under promotion
okay that one was easy okay so it's definitely
a six and just a seven okay this is a fork
you just take it and go check checkmate okay
i didn't see rook f2 but i got lucky there
okay it probably just takes the knight
g3 okay rook g8 queen g3 takes takes
you can also go here it's already getting
tricky okay maybe no no check here is a mate
okay so if i take yes bishop b7 i
think you're supposed to go here first
we're supposed to take okay knight e2
knight f2 knight g3 is that mate oh that's
a very nice one actually quite a beautiful
puzzle okay now where's the rook seat zoom
i feel like i'm okay that's pretty pretty
simple i think we check and just go a6 okay
this is a big chance for me to score
like a big big amount if i don't botch
batch these next couple problems okay so rook rook
d1 what is this queen d6 ah all right everyone
the double uh i'd like to keep you hanging make
sure to follow him on twitter he says gm nero
did yes we have a lot of streamers going in at
the moment and one of them uh we will show you
just a bit i think we're gonna have some good
stuff while we're how's everyone doing today d5
let me ask you that [ __ ] we always ask
where are the string marks from there for so
how are the streamers uh can you win the queen
okay it's a good point to bring out yet i'm
just saying queen e4 is definitely the move
and now probably it's queen f3 yes okay good
okay it's probably oh this is this out this one
i actually know concert benny i know that game
okay check knight f3 looks right
but let's let's think let's all
right let's jump to anna kremlin and see
how she's doing this one it's probably
the g3 where does the queen where does
the queen go where does the queen go
queen takes i don't know we
could take there and then go like
uh queen check oh okay that worked
um doing six to eight in three minutes
that's insane that is actually just insane
okay we got 25
i don't know if it is to take
and then
then we take there wonderful i think we could just
go here bishop takes bishop takes and then pawn
awesome um
what else do we have here check
here is that a move is that a move
hmm i don't see it night here i do not see it
i didn't see that one um wow what i always fail
like two in a row you know it's always like two in
a row that we fail look at this it's always two in
a row that we fail hello cats or thank you thank
you it was my personal best it's 20 oh it's wait
uh all time three nights i know her paying check
is getting even our personal best i know we're
paying i've been there uh so let's quickly move
on i always message you tell us what we missed
another one you might know ladies and gentlemen
okay let's go another one you might
know that we're going to jump into
is international master eric rosen
let's see how he's faring in this puzzle
battle
queen with check that was very important
this is a nice pattern
oh the queen was defending ah okay we're meeting
here or winning the rook um i mean there's rook c7
if we check
oh actually oh no no no no why ah click
click the cursive click click bishop b1 maybe
or no we just push okay i really have to
avoid tilting and avoid mouth slipping
um taken when the queen
oh bishop d8 okay
oh what to do in the rook
yay for puzzles yay for puzzles yeah i'm already
i have two wrong already bishop h3 is interesting
here we go i'm black
take this or push probably push pour
into a queen with check yeah a lot of fun
games there there you go g4 getting a five
i mean each four looks winning no oh not
he's gonna look at it right now he's gonna say
king four king of five and he's gonna say big
i should have listened to you i'm so baffled it
looks winning let's um next please this is kg4
a king here yes yes no it's king of five
or maybe uh king here yes there we go
puppy on the team baby look at that look
at that where's my infinite chat where's
my invite that's what i want to know uh i know
of someone else that's being invited right now
um which is andrew tang he's playing right now
i don't quite look in and see how he's doing
i just i have no self-control
that's not takeable
strange puzzle that
what's this
oh wow oops i thought for sure though is it i
always really like that andrew doesn't really
show emotion the man just moves has 30 000 tabs
open and knows how to play chess leaderboards will
come ladies gentlemen we are working on them right
now so don't worry about that we're going to enjoy
uh i can tell you right now hikaru is doing
really well and now this is doing really well
and i've actually got a a little bit of a
surprise chet just take the piece i guess
who's going to be your next gun i think you might
know him you definitely have to follow the next
person as well that's the move order thing
it's not on there then ali razor ferocious
let's have a quick look at how he's
doing probably because it is three
hours and the highest score will will win
this thing right so yeah let's try our best
i don't think i'm the favorite
but i will try my best
let's check here let's take
on f5 okay let's go 25 26
knight c3 let's go king b3 oh this
was wrong okay let's take on d1
the animation distract you which which animation
there is no animation here let's go rook f5
oh ray robson is playing right okay
that's over then guess what like 100
you couldn't play what like
they didn't let him to play
um let's what is the idea rupee one
takes h2 he wasn't invited that's crazy
that's fair though like if he was
there then there was no chance
okay let's go rook c4 takes let's
go wait i have so many moves here
let's take thank you mp for the tier
one um what should i do these three
the puzzles are getting much harder
nowadays before it was easier i have playing
check and take
um let's go queen h4 coin f2 let's go queen
is mia that was wrong okay let's start again
okay this is one
i guess 55 is the is going to be the best then
if regular option or these guys are not playing
british v slash something how do you raise
sure you hit the follow button uh we're going
to quickly have a look at hikaru who's now
on a 30 streak let's see if he can make it
55.
uh
there's rookie one
wait a second
can you two be three one
this is going really well for him
calculating knight c4 adorable queen before this
is the problem that he has
right now or do we just take
a4 b5 takes takes
i like that he's taking a lot of time here yes
very calm shoot yes the time oh that was good wow
okay i didn't expect that to be actually good no
me neither we need a car we need her i need eight
more right eight more is what i need um what a
beast f3 looks no no okay don't talk focus three
let's stay on this for a bit
chat see how far i can go
i'm sorry
it's kg7 or hsn with h7 this top is
56 by the way yet we're going to uh
show this real quick several h1 here after
this run is 56 at the moment there's a king h7
there we go important um
oh man this is an insane
puzzle it's not fe5 oh this is
this goes on please be right
please be right whoa okay that was a
crazy puzzle it's a 96 or 97 what a beast
i think it's this i mean if it works it works
is it rook f4 queen h6 i think it's this
it's good it's just too easy chad 7.85
right
h5
5 21. h5
queen h7 or
yes good okay yes there we go 55 okay good good
good good good good good good oh he needs to work
one more try to get one more dude wake up wake up
wake up wake up ah okay let's go again i got 55
though i got 55 let's keep going one of these man
what a beast let's look at the leaderboard real
quick ladies and gentlemen uh hikaru is at the
top right now now this is second we have quicker
gm quicker playing as well anna kremling on 29
and eric rosen on 20 forwards it's the leaderboard
it gets updated everywhere uh so make sure now
i'm going to teach you how to be good with puzzle
rush i'm going to give you two very interesting
tips ladies and gentlemen very interesting tips
first of all if you go to the top
right you have a [ __ ] wheel here chad
you have a [ __ ] wheel here you
can put out the animation speed
you could turn it to none make sure it is on none
he is 56 earlier chat you should have 56 earlier
unless it's 55 we'll change that later but the 56
shows on the leaderboard so i'm gonna go over that
i do believe you chet um make sure the animation
type is unknown so in that case whether some none
you don't get like the peace movement it takes a
lot of time so we got that and when you do these
things make sure that you practice your puzzles
like within the 1700 range because that's the ones
you're gonna get the most once you've done that
just regular puzzles set them between thousand
and seventeen hundred and if you challenge
those the most you can do very well iko is
a beast apparently he's 55 i believe he chat um
but what i also believe is that uh you know the
dutch people as the finishing touch god created
dutch i'm one of them another one is anna maya
who's streaming right now let's have a quick look
and see how she's faring in his puzzle rush times
bishop takes d5 first
um yeah what do we do here
there you go that's what we do
wait what was i supposed to do rope
just where where do i put the roof
oh oh you want to do that fine fine
no i refuse to accept that next
no come on i hate that i hate it when it happens
ah i love it what it happens this is content yet
this is contract the pure emotions when you
lose an early 200 puzzles you hate to see it
damn it
okay what is this leaderboard actually
can i check that leaderboard this hour 55
what the actual oh my god look at this
list look at this list what the actual
what am i looking at 55 i've never reached 50. i
have never reached 50. my lord insane uh let's go
hi ali vera hello i was taking it come
on
i was dragging it this is why i hate
dragging uh this is why dragging
what again yeah it's hard to be slower
because uh usually when i do slower ones
i just cannot even make it till 40 because
i'm so slow it's difficult to slow down
ugh
this
all right guys she's struggling a little bit
that's fine one of the leaders at the moment
is quicker and grandmaster quicker we're
gonna have a quick look at him and see
how he's fearing this of these puzzle
rush now we're going to go back to the
form and talk a little bit of the prizes
i'm going to play some post-wars myself
before we go back into the stream but let's
have a look to see how quicker is vary
translation i'm a really good player i think
i like how it's only showing in the bottom
right instead of the entire thing is only
showing the score that's actually really
genius i like that i might use it for myself
and we've got some nice endings
he's doing really well chat
all right well quicker is on the streak doing
really well um i'm going to show really quick
what the format is ladies and gentlemen for
those who are just joining uh for those who are
wondering what we have here today is five minute
puzzle rush three hours long and value streamers
try to score the highest score that they can with
rolling prices each hour so let's focus on today
uh i can also explain for the rest of the days but
for now let's look at today let's see how they are
doing and which prizes they are going for ladies
and gentlemen which is the best overall score gets
a thousand so over three hours and the second
message 750 first second third hour is all 500
i make sure the clip make sure to clip those
that you think have a amazing clip because
they made between 750 will run the twitter
poll later now let's check the leaderboard uh
let's check the leaderboard real quick give
me half a second should be good right now
the leaderboard has given right down chatty
car on 56 at the top daniel narrated to get 54
qriket 38 i'm crumbling at 29 and eric rosen
at 24. we can see how that's going to work out
ray robson has 66 that's not i think the hourly
i think that's his all time if not we will uh
update that soon enough but for now ladies and
gentlemen uh let's play some puzzle rush yourself
let's talk through how it's going through you
actually got 55 i believe you chat we will uh
change that momentarily for now we're gonna play
some puzzles we are gonna play some puzzles don't
worry chad i hear you i hear you i hear you don't
worry about it we'll uh fix that soon enough
once i got a realization how puzzles work and
they work pretty pretty easy man pretty they
work pretty well do we take here i think this is a
point where we take here chad don't worry about it
um all right so this is already should be a mate
right look at that chat it's just too easy these
puzzles are too such a dominating performance on
the board right now let's search for it shoot for
29 i think that's a good point to uh shoot for
right now is this a queen trap it is a queen trap
it is a queen trap here and then i
would have gone queen there all right
so far so good uh check check
doesn't work so let's go check here
rook here win a queen and feel good about
ourselves here i can take this but it's
probably not good enough so let's just take care
oh i should take with the rook what am i doing
i'm trolling chat i'm actually trolling this
game right now but you know it doesn't matter
you guys still like me even if i make mistakes
right chad is is that how this works i hope
that's how it works labor isn't updating
uh we're gonna have a look at it later chad
we're gonna have a look don't you worry about it
for now i need you all to be focused and help me
with these puzzles that's gonna be your only goal
right now chad not to look at the leaderboard to
help with these puzzles uh do i just move my
rook there we go man look at that that was a
pretty difficult one i'm not gonna lie that one
was pretty convoluted but we made at the end
it's like i would tell chad don't worry about it
just don't worry about it we'll make it work we'll
make it work okay now i'm trolling but that's fine
that is what it is um yeah let me just meet you
if i can uh queen here doesn't work i give
a bishop check this oh always check it
might debate let's get a knight i can check
here he runs away with a double check here
that's always seems pretty good
um i think yeah i can take first
really hard end game to win by
the way don't try that at home
oh unlucky man should we come for bishop check
first which makes sense yet just put in the bishop
check first that make sense um let's jump back
real quick to ferocious who is playing pretty well
who's playing pretty well someone's got to tell
about the animation i think someone did by the
way so he's doing pretty well let's jump back in
here and let's get the leaderboards back on track
um let's give a check 93 i cannot focus too
much on the chat because this is very tense so
oh no
rook c8
um queen g3 rook d2
let's go rook f3
knight d3 and take let's go queen e5 rook
e8 knight f7 um let's go here and take here
queen f2 open e1 let me see
four let's connect p6 and a b
okay five let's take on d1 and
go knight f2 knight g3 knight d7
i think it is knight f5 let's go
b7 taken queen i guess it's here
okay queen g3 check let's take on c392
look at the companies machine chats
what an absolute beast let's go
queen of three bishop d4 rook g4
let's take and go rookie wonder which
one this is the bishop is trapped
this could be the run chat for him this could be
the run let's see it's gonna work uh we'll show
the leaderboards apparently the leaderboards
aren't updating properly so we're gonna wait
for that until we show them chat quick sounds
right we're gonna show the accurate information
count every legal puzzle rush score
that's what we say here at chess.com um
we're gonna go it's getting really hard now
though it is pretty hard uh i'll meet ali raza for
yeah that's still again oh that's a muslim
student queen of six and he knows that
there's nothing here you have to be just very
precise you cannot do any move by your intuition
knight g4 then is it queen c5 for nike for how
should i know that what is the difference even
what is the difference what is the
difference here queen c5 knight g4
is it just king of three and king e3 that's
crazy that's crazy just use elevation for rojo
such a likable guy man i really like him another
one of my uh good friends i might say who stayed
on my couch for a week which is breadmaster
amman hamilton let's have a quick look at
how he's doing he's 38 right now and he's doing
really well let's see how puzzle rush is faring
hello nancy this is honestly very boring i look
very boring to watch i'm just like i can't far
can't waste any seconds
just me staring at a screen
wow
oh
i see your comment how do
you pronounce it properly
you know if you tell me how it's not that's
not something we can learn from tell us how
to learn from properly so we can all pronounce
the thing correctly um let's stay on them on
and i'll show the leaderboard in a bit we've got
some new leaders well the leader is still the same
in chicago 55 um but we got some new contestants
for the top five and the hour ends in 19 minutes
so let's take a moment for now and then we'll
look at the leaderboards how they are faring
oh
so
oh no which way is everything going
uh
is it nothing
so
so however there's no real quick chat
ahmad hamilton is now fifth place for 46.
so he needs to get 47 um to improve his
personal best and he's on a great grind to that
let's see if he can make that
we'll show the leaderboards after
this runchat let's stay with him on
let's see if he can make it look at that pose he
needs snow chat he needs to hurry up one minute
that's not a lot of time he's calculating
queen of four doesn't win the end game it
does win the end game queen of four the only
fourth thing there you go and then no e5
yes and then king there very good what a
beast 50 seconds it needs five more can he do
it
uh i got nothing
definitely don't have this one
20 seconds
he's not gonna make it
that's so unfortunate man he's getting so
close let's have a quick look at what are the
leaderboards at the moment ladies and gentlemen
he carnivora i heard you ted we heard you we are
there he's at 55 at the top right now really close
to him only one down is daniel naradiski with 54
points andrew tank 53 algoritha pirogia alareza
i think alireza there you go man i'm nailing it
ray is not included day ray is not playing he's
not participating at this moment because he's
just too good he'll be playing for the world
championship later um so he's not included for
the lookings right now and i'm on hamilton has
46. so we got we got a nice little fair field we
got a nice little field um we're going to keep
going chad we've been in there for 45 minutes
make sure to follow everyone who's participating
including myself which is to be such a bigfoot uh
if you like this kind of content who else has an
incredible overlay you're going to look at this
overlay i'm going to think this is a channel
that i'm going to need to follow grand master
alexandra cosniak just finished on 39 let's see
how she is faring any spells of rush battles okay
why why queen to b6 queen
to b1 then i suppose okay
and um and the ones that i just missed
when was it was this stalemate okay and
what's next that was the question that's why
i tried to figure it out for such a long time
okay then rook a5 king king two
i'm just going to c5 that's idea if he takes
i take with the with the rook and instead
after rook a4 king to d5 okay okay i realize
okay the first one was not great but it just
they're just the beginning oh i love that
gallery and chat you gotta learn my speed
and get first to this uh 2021 top score which
is okay okay bishop h2 is a little bit premature
okay
premature move let's focus
on the mature one instead
okay
a few more checks check me if you can
wait no not mouse sleep
again please no pretty please
i am white he's on a good run right now
chuck to be on a leaderboard right now
you need to get at least 46 okay that's
what it'll be about at the moment i got it
if we need them while we can
okay now this one is easy
something should be easy right once in a while
not always the most difficult path should be
chosen oops yes oh no just queen takes d5 okay
it's not that interesting after all oh come on
come on
okay
many many many many checks
okay one more again and like
this and rook h1 rook h3
okay double attack one of the greatest
i'll do it in here
no idea one minute and 30 seconds left um i'm
actually quickly going to jump over to neroditsky
who's at 40 who just made a mistake and he has
two and a half minutes left let's have a look
i probably missed some defense oh i meant to
take the rook it always does that i i press
the square first and then i press the and it
automatically moves the piece to that square
i don't know i have to disable that feature
ah this one i think you go
bishop d6 and give you a slot
it's not taking on g6 okay i guess
we have time for one more run
g6 so i guess i take and go queen
c1 okay it's pretty easy
yeah that was queen g5
win the queen oh wait i guess just takes
probably just takes watch me get 56 on this
one that'd be a classic nerdisky thing to do
i'm a buzzer beater
okay and now probably we castle long but not sure
oh wait i ca that's an illegal move it's actually
just here okay 40. okay i should be able to do
this let's just [ __ ] let me just take five
seconds okay let's focus bishop f4 and takes
rook h8 queen h2 queen b8 is
mate it's definitely b2 and here
okay now this one is probably rookie six repeat up
i don't know should be
seven ship f5 i don't see it
i don't know i i have no idea what this one
is he's really close yet i'm actually going
to quickly swap over to the hour one leader
board that we have right now because here
the car nakamura is first 55 down here
to see a second with 54. andrew ting
andersen and mon 48 and 46. and quicker
eric little anna maya and anna kremling
in the top 10 afterwards so there's a bit of
a gap between the fifth and sixth place but
it's all about the top three chat it's all about
that top three actually the most important part
it's about the top one the razer just got 54 what
a beast it's going to be updated quickly let's
quickly jump into narratives can see how he's
doing weird like selection of problems sometimes
man this one is just incredibly
difficult
okay queen c2 or queen a2 it's probably queen
a2 because it's a counterintuitive move yep
maiden one okay
i don't know rook h8 rook ga maybe come on
how long does this have to last oh my god
oh it's not b5 it's rook b8 and then b5 what
is this on rugby 8 oh and rugby and bishop c7
yeah cyber alard thank you
that was a good one though
i guess i have time for one more or will it
not count because i won't finish it in the
allotted time he's going for his final round now
ditski um we're gonna quickly jump into hikaru
just there finish his last self he
is the top leaderboard at the moment
actually scratch that i heard alleria look at the
turbo right now let's jump i'm going to jump into
that real quick we see that eddie raza just made
into the top now there were a question what if
there is a tie break what we're going to is going
to end up the number of places that are tight
and we're going to have split money for that
so that how we go we're going to we're going
to split it out let's see how the razer
he's on his last run it should be there's
only three minutes left this hour chat the scores
are going to be reset then and we're going to see
how that's going to work out uh actually
he has a bug in the stream so let's jump
back to hikaru and see if he can manifest
his position right now let's take and take
they both got 54 you guys are trolling
what do you guys keep saying 54 58 59 so
what are you guys talking about he did
54. you guys are still trolling like yeah
yeah good job you guys good job he got 54.
unbelievable let's go check good debate though
good debate i'm just doing one to sort of start
over okay yeah let's let's just wait let's just
wait okay let's just let's just let's just wait
let's just wait for the next one or no why
did i start a new one whatever okay whatever
okay i'll just wait till okay it's 10 58 so we'll
just we'll just wait for two more two minutes
um and then we'll get going but yeah i think
it's important if you get if you get a big start
um to not go insane it's it's just like you need
you need to stay very chill and very relaxed um
so yeah thank you to phoenix for the prime deckard
payne for the prime day assertive with prime ziggy
ue for the prime minitel denton roads for the
prime banjo x please for the prime thank you to
gabe gramps for the prime chancellor for the prime
smokey xn for the prime the optimus brand for the
prime simon craig for the prime lazarus small p
for the prime thing takes and bishop v5 rook f8
28 and a5 takes
listen guys he didn't want to hear what
i was going to say anyway so that's why
i moved it myself i'm saving you from
myself all right don't worry about it
it was the first queen of b3 it's weird
um okay what is going on knight to six
i don't know um
okay this is very hard now
all right it is over for now the
first hour is done these aren't the
confirmed top 10 yet they're going to work on it
right now but this is the top 10 that i have at
place at the moment hikaru being the number one 55
points their idea this key is the second with 54.
uh ali reza is 54 as well and routine 53 i'm on
46 and even under maya bring it to the top 10.
um these guys will go on i'm gonna take
a quick three-minute break to make some
things working while we're on a break let's uh
let's keep it on daniel near this key and see
how the new leaderboard will start out with him
maybe he'll be on top so you guys three bets
that's pretty harsh i gotta say all
right hello let's get first then
oh but somebody's gonna get above all
right i can figure out when to take breaks
yeah it's just here i'll just do a little bit more
i'm not really feeling this this is just grueling
we have to i mean always they trick me
you'll always find a way to trick me
okay
three hours of this is just ridiculous
i'm already like lost my motivation
okay maybe some music will help
okay
i got the pace but you guys
have to understand this is
how can it how can it not be rook i mean that is
like the most natural move in the history of chess
and it's like not that well they know exactly how
to do that i love it when doing that struggling
man hey i love dania and he's doing really
well and i hope he gets all the prizes but i
do love it when people uh get frustrated for chess
because jess it's a fair game chat you play bad
you lose you play good you win um that's the
way it is and i think dania is going to make
it really well i hope he stays all the way
through even though this is a grueling event
let's see how uh grandmaster alexander
constantinix is now reviewing the pulse
every time she gets one wrong she reviews it see
what was better i'm not sure if that is the way
to move forward but let's have a quick look
at how she is doing something should not be
very difficult and then yes i was about
to play k2f6 but but i'm getting there
am i live right now am i am i alive right now am
i dreaming uh yeah so we got to 42 not to 43 43
uh well i should become first of all
i'm competing with myself which is
43 my top score today's top score is 43 and i
want to get there or at least i'm getting caught
why do i keep muting myself listen chad all right
don't worry about it don't worry
about it everyone uh my name is rick
um i've got a good question here about what is the
format and we're going to look at the format real
quick to see how it is you know so i can get my
face on screen and you don't see me blush anymore
chad there we go um what is the format what do
we have going on for now it was perfect thank
you for the lip readers and chats listen twitch
and chest if you chat it doesn't matter come here
um five minute puzzle rush score
is right now i'm gonna play three
hours where the top of each hour gets prize money
and one overall so it's three hours of grueling
five minute puzzle rush for tomorrow survival mode
will have invited streamers power up in teams of
two who score the highest possible survivor
score they can win with the rolling prices
that we have right now puzzle 3 is a 16 player
bracket which is gonna be amazing and day four
is freeman on puzzle rush where we're gonna have a
special host uh it seems right now cannot confirm
tomorrow we'll have maurice ashley by the way
he will not be muted um or maybe i will you know
we'll think about it i'll take into consideration
and they five is the puzzle battle championship
with the big prize money is now what are the prize
money for today best overall score gets a thousand
second best overall school to get 750
and then it's all the best in one hour so
we're gonna see if icaru is gonna get all that
stuff do i owe the seven string guitar i do not
but i do like a chat and who i also like
is uh hikaru nakamura was on a 37 streak
at the moment so we will do that right now we're
going to jump into that and then let's see if we
get the leaderboards up so make sure to follow all
the streamers that you like make sure to follow me
if you like me i don't know why all my streams
are muted by the way but they have good content
and that's all that matters let's have a
quick look and see how icaru is pairing up
f6 just
what's that f4
oh it's that foreign queen hooks up so bad at
me um okay let's think rook d4 is a move i see
the top of hikaru is already 53 takes takes that's
good okay as long as i don't panic here i'm still
in good shape take some takes 98 and e7 is
a move but that seems a little bit weird um
maybe it just is rookie six and
just takes okay that's weird
queen g twosome with queen g3 is number
two one and just check and take that's good
okay and this one you go check here here it
takes of course um 97 is a move it must be right
it just takes it's good there's some puzzle with
the queen getting how do you do this checking e5
is it f4 or something or is it bishop b6 and
this is some kind of weird puzzle geometry
um i honestly have no clue 96k5 and
it's this okay and track intakes okay
um wait this one this should be pretty obvious
what am i missing i guess just this this and that
okay good it should be pretty obvious how
could you not see that chats this is some kind
of force mate that uh there's no way i know
i'm gonna get this right it's so obvious b3
where's me checking me crazy puzzle
94. yeah too hard too difficult
30 seconds left it's going to be tough to see
if he can make this this is a really hard one
is it h5 yeah i don't even know what this one is
alireza got 53 too yeah that's not surprising um
actually no i what is this one
sir what is this one oh wow
um we're gonna quickly have a look at
hashtag chat so i haven't looked at her
just yet she's been playing really well
she's been on the leaderboards so what
let's have a look and see how she's varying oh
no that's a major one do we go there and then we
let's check we should probably take yes
and then we take here we don't take the
bishop because then we lose all the pieces
here we probably need to we have a past pawn
so we do things ah we go there because then
we had a we had a fork if they take it back
that makes sense and then this it's very
scary when you click a piece because you
don't know if you're gonna if you're going
to do a mouse slip we can take here i don't
think that works we could take here
i don't quite see the point in that
i can go here but then the rook just protects
you just have four so what is the point of this
puzzle oh it's two in the night winning
the main it was the floor makes sense
and then moving because we're in check sorted
let's stay on with our four minute chat and then
we're gonna look at we're gonna place a puzzle
rush ourselves so i'm gonna need you to help me
get that high score get on the leaderboard it's
okay rock h and we'll show the leader king takes
but then the king just goes back now i'm looking
at rook h7 isn't that it's not that that was
not the correct move what is happening
why do i keep on getting theoretically
theoretically i'm getting easy puzzles wrong but
we're getting a lot of twenty hate to see a chat
i'm back unmuted for this time so you know we're
only going up we're only going up chat uh that's
how it's going and we're gonna play some puzzle
rush ourselves let's see who's in the top right
now it is ikaru nakamura being in first obviously
with 53 eli riza uh 53 as well then anna maya
kazarian doing really well too for oh yeah i'm not
muted yet let me mute myself real quick or else
you know it's not the real big food experience
i'm on hamilton 42 and alexander kostinick the
chess queen has 42 as well do we have a top 10
ready i do have a top 10 ready because that's how
you do it here ladies and gentlemen eric rosen
is on the tail as well number six little cordis
corrids 36 daniel merdeski having a tough time
only 33. he can bounce back andrew tank 33 and
quicker as 30. so we're going to see who's
going to end this up probably going to be
a battle between hikaru and anariza until i
joined the freight chat we're going to sweat
we're going to do it we're going to play some
puzzle rush 5 minutes let's see how we fare
ourselves already look at that animation
look at speed chats the speed of a demon
you thought cheetahs are fast look at my games oh
my god hikaru who is ikaru look at me okay what
am i doing closer to it's just c7 [ __ ] come
on okay we're gonna retwist it nobody saw that
all right nobody needs to clip that we didn't
see that we're just gonna get these all right
i need at least a little bit of a normal score so
all right if we do this again i'm going to quit
stream chat if i stuck on free again i'm going
to quit this stream with my job yeah yeah yeah
you heard it you heard it all right we got free
we're safe chat we're saved woo that's a close one
that was a close one chet that was the yikers oh
we made it look at that um i'm white i'm black
or some blackjack of course we are black
um you go check here this all works
what is this check check give me that give me that
give me you there we go okay this is going to be
fairly easy there we go boom boom boom i want you
in my room and i think we'll go for this one and
put this one doing a good
job doing fine a double time
there's nothing that can stop us today uh
want to get the night here how do we do that
without getting destroyed huh okay this
is actually a difficult one i don't see
is it just is it just this it is just that
okay i thought i could win the queen there so
uh apparently we didn't think of check okay you
know what uh that was my bad it's not always
my opponent's fault it's just
queen rook here go with material
we do win material chat look at that doing good
leaderboards are being updated yet you can see
it in the bottom right now so we can have it
is it rook here or rook here or knights under
attack so it's knight there there it is boom um
did you just run away oh oh oh let's not do that
let's not do that eh
um okay this seems like a trap it's like
something i can trap but i'm not too
sure yet let's just check do we grab stuff what is
this one okay honestly there's not a puzzle here
i'm gonna give a check and it's gonna be
wrong there was just not a puzzle there
it was not a puzzle it was not there if i don't
see it yet it's not a puzzle as simple as that
you can you can tell me otherwise you can
tell me otherwise that's just the way it is
um we're gonna look at these real quick
and then we're gonna scooch back is it
it's not a check here it's not a check there
do we take here first and then go check it
this seems like the most obvious
way i think we just start running
do we take it do we start running we take because
now we do it with check aha look at that chat
look at that mate we are doing excellent i
think it's bishop here there we go i have a
chair oh this is a beautiful one look at that
look at that baby look at that is it just take
i'm not sure why it wouldn't be taken now
here's interesting i think we just go king
first and do i go here do i dare to go there
i think we do
huh
yeah we do yeah we do and then you'll
create there okay i got it i found it
that is what it's 28 is fine chat 28 do it do it
listen chad i didn't get enough inputs for you
so this is all on you all right
i'm not i'm washing my hands
in innocence um let's look back at el riza
el riza is playing a phenomenal thing uh he's
doing really well so let's have a quick look
at him and see how he's doing uh during these
things
i mean both are winning again okay
okay this is not good did anybody
do in the second hour like 55-56 or
you're struggling too what was the highest
so quick out of this chat the leaderboard
doesn't only show five minute ones it's only show
also shows the three-minute ones on chess.com
that's why the leaderboard that i have is the
most accurate hikaru or whatever that is a
beast by the way thank you q in for the sub
i just wanted to mention
that the beast from the east
ikari okay
i did 53 too right or i did 52 or 53. no i did 52.
i did use this three
you did 53 and theresa and someone else also did
let's quickly look at that daniel neroditsky has
joined the leaderboards that's right down
there this key also now 53 he car on 53
and anariza is also on 53 so they're all doing
fine and dandy let's see how that's going to
work out let's actually go back to edinburgh not
go back to el riza he just lost his thing let's
uh let's jump to narendri and see how
he's faring he must be feeling pretty good
it's always like the tricky
little move that's the issues
i want to get 40 in every run that
would be like a professional thing to do
foreign
it
oh
yeah this is easy i like the end games
the pawn end games are always easy
we want more end games
nice pawn games some nice music chat
i'm only a bit i'm a bit down that he
doesn't dance oh i wanted to see some
narrative dancing oh there's your game is
it kidney 6 it's h6 oh i hate to see it man
my skills are superior you're right you're
right i just need to calculate okay this is good
plenty of time i know that's what it sounds
like but it's not actually the case guys
because when you get to the 50s it's like you need
30 seconds for a problem just to work out
what's going on okay rook f is it rook h1
yeah i mean queen f5 is probably wrong
but it looked like it was winning
let's stay in the streak a little bit longer
chat and then we're gonna have a look at the
leaderboards we're gonna have some more look-ins
i'll explain the format again and then we're gonna
play some puzzle marsh ourselves and i need
to check but he's better at solving these
difficult problems than i am i'll need to
check the beater i i start to stumble on
these films i i don't know what's going on
i need like five minutes for a problem here
i mean i have no idea what the
solution is rook f2 e8 queen
i don't get how you solve these so fast oh i mean
seeing that idea that was a cool
one take some time no i agree
that's why it's a 2600 puzzle and
it is it's not king g8 it's king g7
mine all right it didn't make it
he did not make it let's see the leaderboard
for now it's still icaru first daniel ii and and
theresa is third even though they all share their
ties uh andamaya dwarf anamaya playing really
well actually wrm and amaya um let's look at her
i'll show you how she is faring at these days and
like i said afterwards we'll look at the format
please impossible ourselves we're gonna have some
great time in this puzzle week if you don't
puzzle if you love puzzles you're gonna love
this week let's see what under my is doing she
is in the zone right now jet let's have a look
what
i know why it's wrong but it still hurts
or a moment of thought we were
looking at like uh his name
little little john
that one's bad no
you thought it was jack mate that there's
a paul on g3 yeah i hate to see it man
yeah i hate to see it how do you get
44 all right that's what i want to know
come on come on all right chad
let's jump back to an unmuted big i do have
guitar [ __ ] yo january 10th i'm gonna have
a 24 hour stream to hit 10k followers um so make
sure to follow my channel if you haven't already
twitch the v slash bigfoot where i will be
streaming i'll play some guitar then we're
not gonna spread some guitar right now because
right now we gonna look at the format and the
format is really easy yet it's five minutes of
puzzle rush three hours long or each hour they
will win money overall with money and the
follow-up will win money look at the money
thousand dollars for overall score second best
overall score 750 that's the first hour which was
icarua second and best hour best in second
hour and best in third hour i'm gonna have
the clip the twitter poll i was gonna doing ray
robson isn't on uh this day he'll be on other
days because ray robson is infinitely better than
all the streamers combined uh i'm not exaggerating
that easies so let's get you real quick day one
five minutes of puzzle rush as stated day two
it's all the same it's all the same time you come
here you take a snack you take your popcorn we're
gonna play some puzzle rush that's the way it is
while we open up the leaderboard we're gonna have
to look at eric rosen real quick chad because
he is also on a grind now on 44 even though the
beasts are still tired 53 we're gonna see how that
is going all right everyone ready make sure the
to jiggle make sure is there a host command by
the way just a uh a quick thing there we go baby
there we go the legend himself was impossible
five minutes let's win we go that one is easy
okay we are on a roll already chad we are
on a roll is that a mate that is a mate
can you imagine getting made it over the board
on that that's uh that's an unfortunate change
circumstances i'm just getting mates here i like
these ones it's just take take take take take
um is it take here yes and you
take here on b2 easy as that yet
easy as that um that seems pretty good as well
i'm not gonna lie i wanna play oh this one's no
yes this one that was a really difficult one by
the way hello everyone welcome to the stream make
sure to follow everyone that is being displayed
today some fantastic streamers uh and myself
i'm not saying that i'm a fantastic streamer i'm
just saying oh i'm trolling man okay what if i
check that i can win the pawn i like pawns chad
is it just winning a pawn that can't be right
okay well it isn't right let's start with the one
it's busy before all right all right i'm gonna
keep going until i uh i'm gonna be satisfied yet
i need to be a satisfied man look at
that the same made twice you hate to
see it or you love to see it depending on
which side of the board you're on is it
let's check right here it is just a checkmate
there there's some really cool checkmates in
these sometimes they're really hard and i'm like
how do you even how is this a 200 puzzle you know
that's what i'm sometimes wondering when i see
these puzzles i'm like how is this a 200 puzzle
that's not correct uh let's take there you know
a friendly capture a friendly capture here's also
a friendly capture uh i could yeah let's just
take this where's the mate is it just check here
seems very promising and it is very promising
i can take here there's going to be a check at
the end i feel like that's the idea but um it's
concerned on what to do here okay but okay hold on
it ends with this it starts with
this that's the one chat thank you
i didn't look at yet but i'm going to believe that
you guys told me the correct answer and i want to
thank you for that you guys are beasts what am
i without my chat right she before pretty okay
seems pretty okay oh my god dude i'm killing
it okay i shouldn't have said it i'm gonna
jinx myself um you just check here now let's
check here now do we take here no do we take
here he takes here we have a check he runs away
what do i do here okay i'm gonna take here and
i'm going to ponder what i need to do now just
check here and here it is that wow how did you
not know that chad i'm just asking how did you
not see that it's kind of cringe bishop here
23 okay we're on a roll uh it's black and this is
a very very easy end game that everybody should
know this is just a free knight and i think we're
gonna go queen here oh he's attacking this as well
so we're just going to grab that and feel
good about ourselves i think check check boom
we're killing a chat honestly we're doing good
and huh where's the mate where is the mate
no honestly where's the mate
i'm asking you guys i don't know
i actually do what if i go rook here okay watch
this okay don't watch it go back go back to what
you were doing don't watch it it's fine nobody had
to see that oh i'm trolling dude what are we doing
what am i actually doing all right okay what do i
check take 27 what am i doing see this is why i'm
not here chad this is why i don't participate
i'm actually trolling doing these things
uh you can see leaderboard everybody is still on
53 let's bring the love back to eco some 43 at
the moment these are growing days if you only
keep pumping out puzzle rush it's really much
yeah it's probably a booked xb7 first i uh i
miscalculated that one hate to see it number
one host thank you everyone i appreciate that like
i said exclamation mark host if you like this kind
of content make sure to follow my channel and also
make sure to follow the car nakamura wrong order
let's go check
um i forget which pawn which is it it takes now
it's something weird like it's bishop b3 or is it
or is it queen i can't remember the correct
move here i've seen this puzzle before
uh king g1924 is no good
okay i think you make a queen but i
no but you don't make a queen
could be bishop a2
i honestly don't know it is bishop too
okay
oh it's queen eight oh uh is is it
queen eight or no it's queen a7 queen a7
let's go here and here
let's take a check and go check
let's go chuck and mate take
the queen trap the knight
how is someone this good chat like honestly
what a beast after this one will show the
leaderboards again to see who is going through
yikes he's disgusted with himself
that he gets something wrong
and it's like i'm just going to move to the next
one look at the leaderboards at the moment he
carl is still first type of detonating in el
erisa eric rosen on 44 and a maya on 44 and
there's also another anna that we haven't looked
at which is anna kremlin let's see how she's doing
right now okay so i don't need to think about what
the pieces are doing i need to fill the pieces
right that's what we need to do we just need to
fill the pieces yeah i'm not sure if that's gonna
hold up in court uh miss kremlin let's see i'm
literally a tree hugger yes i am i like my trees
or my trees i like the tree it's been nice
and kind to us check and then we win a wreck
i was trying to do a little king jump there king
jumps are apparently not a thing boom and boom
boom and boom
i mean this has to be a bit the biggest
boom ever there checkmate let's see
i can that one okay 20 all right
takes takes rick here on here good
there and there and
let's see okay it's at this point
that they start to be a bit hard
hmm night take some queen
takes night not knight takes
okay there um takes no takes no
which one is it takes my can't be takes
there's still two there's still two
minutes left super scary music this is super
scary music this is like really scary music
don't care about the music anna play i gotta make
a move not the one so an hour and a half left
what's the plan here what's the plan
i mean i i don't know what the plan was in that
one i think it was king c4 trying to trap the rook
let me take there bishop check or no bishop check
bishop check there
queen takes knight check and then we take boom
it was knight takes b3 okay let's just do this
let's just do this oh i am because we're okay
all right all right it's not it's not that
one yeah all right let's jump really quick
to eloreza who is on a god run right now 42 two
and a half minutes left can he make it to the top
um rook a1 knight c1 h3 queen
okay knight c6 on 26 um knight g4
but then he goes f4 though i have
h6 is it h6 okay um luxie eights
um he's on 50 guys this is a big moment he still
has a minute okay 51. this is going to be the run
let's try for an hour it's going to be
a split money day gonna be split money
is he going to do it 52 this is
going to be huge if he makes it
he's on 53. if he gets this one right he
will be the new leader oh my god 30 seconds
if he guesses one right he is the new leader
you got it you got it 54.
oh my god you got 55 congrats
alariza coming in what a beast man
what a beast rookie it is
not luke h3 oh rook is so mad
what a beast congrats man still 19
minutes left rook takes three g2
queen of fun queens don't
tell me it's just rook c3
it is just looks it's real all right let's see
if hikaru heard the news an hour reacts to it
28 just wins the game for white that's why
i don't oh oh the pawns guarded never mind
yeah ollierez got 55. i had 55 in the first hour
um as well but the difference is that i feel like
i'm fading here like i'm just not seeing the
puzzles as well anymore let's take chuck takes
no i had 55 i didn't get 56.
um
there's something where you force him to make like
a bishop or something i don't
remember how this one goes
i've seen this puzzle before but
i just don't remember how it goes
i just don't remember that one there's
some there's some way that you can do it
oh do i have 56 oh i thought at 55. leaderboard
says 56 i thought it was 55 but maybe i'm wrong
was it 56 or was it 55 i thought it was 55 all
right let's have a quick look at the leaderboard
ladies and gentlemen uh alariza is the number one
with 55. icaru 53 at the moment darren diskey also
53 and then a bunch with 54. let's look real quick
again what the prices are that they're working for
the best in the second hour which is and
theresa at the moment is getting 500 dollars uh
in the first hour it was hikaru nakamura
with 55 that made first and anoriza had 54.
i don't have those at hands right now but i might
be able to scooch one in while we're looking at
some of the other streamers for sure so let's
jump back to nerds he's been doing really well
he's 30 now with four minutes left so that's
definitely something to look at and after that
we're going to play some possibilities soft
chat let's have a quick look probably bishop c5
i don't see a defensive bishop c5
there probably is one i just
don't see it just incredible
there's probably some mate some easy
oh
each one was i didn't see
them made immediately these
puzzles are so cruelly from down to time chat
they can be so cruel i definitely can
and they definitely are we're gonna
see how this is going to unfold
so
mmm that's a nice one
okay bishop
over here that's a check um you're correct
chad these beasts are machines let me flash
the leaderboard again real quick
alluriza at the number one place now
the karna konora's second key is third
so we're going to jump back to the origin
afterwards we're going to have a quick look
into eric rosen who's also playing pretty well
but not on par with the top three who are
just absolute machines let's continue back
to neroditsky and see how he's running in
with his puzzle rush streak still going on
oh my god
these are just ridiculous
i was supposed to find a great random
quiet move in the end of that line
versus these incredible selection
of problems this time around
and i should be able to solve it it's not
an excuse but i'm just not expecting it
thanks laura absolutely two years
yeah this one i have no idea
it's probably here wow
what's that
all right guys i'm done after this one
second oh hate to hear that it might be done for
the entire tournament but you can also take a 10
minute break and then reset uh because that's our
thing okay let's try to go for 50. all right chad
um like i said we're gonna look at i am roasting
real quick let me know what you guys want to see
what we're here to provide some entertainment for
you guys obviously trying to get the streamers
some more clouds as the cool kids say let me know
who would you like to see uh what we can improve
that's why we're here humble big here who's not
muted we're making some progress uh let's jump
back to i am rosen then it's only a few minutes
left we're gonna do a quick puzzle brush ourselves
you know we're gonna get on the leaderboards
before we see the end of it so let's see mr rosen
he's been doing pretty well i'll show you
i'll flash the standings real quick after
this chat um this is actually very oh it's
his first mistake oh maybe rook f6 or rook g6
check that one out there you
go i just wanted to rush 44.
that's the curse absolutely g4
oh g4 you're losing that
three nylon freeze on defended
okay a minute left it's gotta be bishop e5
you gotta take that
hmm wow that's impressive that was impressive
uh robson isn't participating for today because
he's just on another level queen h5 has an idea
i'm not seeing it
and queen f7 looks just to be the most solid move
looking good
six seconds come on tiger score
unlucky around the time unlucky
and the rook's hanging on eight but my queen's
also hanging question is how to how to proceed
so close yet so far away ladies and gentlemen
where's andrew tang he's uh hiding at the bottom
of the leaderboard right now he has 42 will
jump into him after this hour there's only
eight minutes left which means that we can do
one quick puzzle rush uh ourselves and you guys
can keep the leaderboards uh in check to see
who are winning so let's stay on this one so
we can see the leaderboards uh while we play some
puzzle rush ourselves should always be from chat
to see if we can make it with the big boys if
we can call ourselves the big boys uh i almost
took here you hate to see that that wouldn't
be a very big boy moment uh if i did that
but so far it's going pretty
well chet we're doing really good
jack we win the queen uh here it's gonna be a
check and i think it's we're gonna run it down
we did run it down and that's a mate
it's a little bit more difficult um
huh wait what this is this is an 800 puzzle i
should know this there we go okay i'm not sure
why that took me so long chet sometimes
you get those puzzles where you're like
what am i exactly supposed to do here and this was
one of them but this is like a very thematic thing
you see these ones pretty fast just like this one
pretty thematic just like this one pretty framatic
i like it when they're pretty
thematic as you can tell
because i could win them quickly um this seems
pretty easy where i need to defend this somehow um
bishop here what a move what a beastie
boy move here again with a double attack
we are doing this very well is it
f4 i think it's just going to be f4
and it's all defended so we are good here
it's a check i think i'm gonna run here
all right so far so good uh
here it's should be a mate
right here okay so we are doing good chat
we have the leaderboard underscore right
here so where alireza is too strong
he's a beast he's an absolute monster
he is an absolute monster is his check here and go
queen here or is it just oh what is this one chat
i'm thoroughly confused this just
work here i'm gonna go rook here
it was work there nice so here i think it's check
and run like a hit or run i need to do something
so here that he plays here
all right i'm not gonna i'm not gonna cry about
it we'll take it stay here take a free piece
we're actually doing really well
chad look at that we're beasts
this looks like a mate but you know i've been
wrong before we have been wrong before um
so i think it's just fake and then take yep and
in yeppers in chat we want to trade queens to
this punk and run how do you do that how does
one do that i can also pick up this button
not gonna be the one unfortunate queen here mate
it is queen there i made nice um
this just looks like i should do this
if we do this and he takes
here what's what's the catch
oh come on man that was so close that was so close
i hate to see it um we are 30 so i'm going to be
happy with that as well i'll wait for the final
seconds the final moments of the things to tick
down for this hour let's see if we can get a few
more right i want to go knight here to attack this
and that is the solution
check their check there i don't think
that's it i think we just do this right now
huh is it this that's not i probably should have
taken it first look at this one real quick chad
also not it okay
just take the rook it's easy that so jimbo the
monk welcome let's have a quick look at the top
10 as it is alireza still on the top of 55. he
currently camaro 53 there it is 53 there's only
three minutes left let me check in real quick
if one of them is close icaro has 42 and daniel
has 45 but also two or wrong let's quickly jump
into ricardo and see if he can make it to 55.
yeah that's wrong i knew that was
wrong the moment i played it b7 can be
queen three
so foreign
yeah i have no time no time i i need
to catch like some really hot streak
and pray that everything works basically
okay we got a gamble gamble gamble gamble
yeah i i had to gamble there i had no time i
had to gamble yeah my best score this hour was
53 i think yeah it was not a good score
it's a bad car is not going to make it
oh he's trying to get 50. that is unlucky
let's go back to eloisa who uh granted eight
this one in the middle that i got wrong
was really the the that second one that
i got wrong was actually i shouldn't
start because there's no way i set a new
record so whatever let's just let's just
start over uh yeah that was not so good
uh thank you to andre oh yeah of the prime glitch
for the prime d chechuan with the prime thank you
so much thank you to broken axles thank you to uh
lee sin for the tier one thank you to pippi drippy
for the prime real quick for the prime ninjas with
the tier 1 men with the prime buddy holly uh buddy
holly mall cop with the prime sheeps thank you
jessica for being here thank you for everyone
for being here thank you you guys for watching for
being here thank you so proud of putting cac w in
chat for being here thank you all for being here
i'm not making fun i'm just learning from the best
chat or learning from the best and that concludes
this hour we only have a few seconds left
let's look at the points absolutely what are the
scores i feel you chat i see you you ask and you
shall receive and there is a the top with
55 congrats on him he should take the money
uh unless someone else pumped in real quick the
current look more 53 there near this d53 uh i'm on
hamilton 45 we're gonna jump in with someone one's
doing pretty well as well so the second hour win
will go to alireza we still have one hour left
of puzzle rush battle of puzzle rush uh goodness
uh it's i think penguin gm just stopped uh
unfortunately we're gonna see how it's going to
work out and it should be that i see iron imrozen
is now on 41 and because he started earlier
this score should work for a new hour so
i'm going to see how it's going to work out
um i'm going to take a quick break until
then we're going to put up hikaru and see him
get some new closures course let's go mate wait
this is wait you take black ones go down the board
i mean i guess you just take
and take with the rook um
it should be winning takes check takes is
good takes and just take the rook is good um
i mean i guess
check first 94 something weird i don't understand
that puzzle rush that's just a weird one
i mean i wonder if i should
just take i should tank this
about 27 so i guess i shouldn't tank this one yet
oh wait trucking cakes
it's working okay now i'm gonna tank
and i'm just gonna take this one that
was a terrible first one take a 30
minute nap yeah no no definitely not
i mean i had one where i could have gotten into
the mid 50s which i messed up like 49 or something
uh after the very first one but
mate
check check check and made is good um
this work h8 worksheet and it takes takes
you just do this and takes free juicer on g6
free everything what is this just takes and takes
and theresa won the second
hour with 55 that is correct
the last one still has 57 minutes
chat which is going on right now
uh i guess you push or d oh oh man
i guess you okay that's good
well eloise didn't get 56 he got
55. okay what is this takes nerf d4
leaderboard takes a little while chat probably
another five minutes so i can show the leaderboard
because you know they're gonna get the scores
in we got this thing who's playing three minutes
just playing five minutes so um it's gonna take
a little bit longer at the start of the season
as they could say i'm doing pretty
well we still have 57 minutes left
we still have 57 minutes
left 23 maybe no knight e2
queen 392 there's no good
move knight you two richie two
um it's queen g2 why did i
do that that was so stupid
what is this d1 knight p6 c5
yeah this one i don't even know
what the move is i'm just blind
i mean i guess it's this and this
i honestly don't know but it works
okay t3
i kind of need to gamble i'm low
on the clock here so i should just
gamble that's pretty good at puzzles
so i don't know if it's uh it's not a
maybe it's this i should just gamble
here okay knight e3 work a five okay
seven maybe
okay how do you stop this
checking seven pretty good
okay it's good i think it's it's is it d7
or ace i think it's this and then it's like
this and it's like is it check
on each sir after i think it's
okay
must be chuck oh it's work up too shoot oh man
check is it okay each one
no it's got to be a check
now i think it's takes in here
i have no time though 50 though that's really
good queen i got a rook or a still mate
that's genius you had to get a rook there
or else it's still mate wow what a beast
no
ah okay so wait somehow somehow i got to
53. don't ask me how i don't know how i got
to 53 there that was actually i was i think i
guess i got lucky at the end with those puzzles
but that's pretty good 53 to start with that
is an amazing score for ricardo so he puts
himself on the leaderboard my name is bigfoot
i'm the host and producer of today ladies and
gentlemen bringing you all the entertainment
that we're trying to do shameless prague real
quick on the sunday this sunday i'm holding
a 24 hour stream if you like 24 hour streams
with all kinds chess switches to v-slash bigfoot
we're going to get the leaderboards up soon let me
quickly join in on the format what's going on
here today five-minute puzzle rush three hours
long now in the final hour and each hour they
can win horizons let's look at those prizes
right now uh the best in the first hour we'll see
carla gomorrah he'll win 500 the best and second
hour was alireza who won 500 dollars and now we're
going to see who's going to be the best in the
third hour we don't have the leaderboards up just
yet they're being placed in so we have patience
i do have big feet men that is true i do have
big feet let's have a quick look at the one and
only grandmaster i'm on hamilton and see how he's
faring with these giants that he's competing with
i'm like
yeah annoying
that's not an easy one
you know the position that i just saw can anyone
remember the game that david the legend played
i think it's dave the legend that
knight b3 check with bishop on b5
the funny thing is i swear that tactic for like
david's literal game like it's the same position
that david played on stream i'm just like a
random thought i think it's actually like his team
like knight b3 check in the sicilian
like
how much is the level one we're gonna
need to switch chat because alarisa has
one minute left is on 47 and he might
this might be the run so let's have a look
look 88 okay can't be um
i will take okay who keeps three nights 49 is
huge for that is huge oh first take this guy
top is 53 by the way chad for this hour the
car was also top 53 are you just thinking of f8
no oh man
we can't see how many he's got wrong troll man
all right 51 this is going to be the run chat
oh there are many moves i
have so many options here
pick the right one yeah i have
oh unlucky man so many options
these are the ones you're gonna hate yourself the
most because if you only waited like a few more
seconds of calculation it could be like difference
between nothing and a thousand dollars you know
your car was at 50 right now let's have a look
played i could have gone i could have gotten
52 for sure there i could have gotten 52 there
if i if i had like 10 seconds more i would
not have made that mistake there at the end
oh whoops wrong there are
multiple checkmates there
apparently but i played the wrong one let's take
okay queen takes h6 just wins right just takes
what is oh native
okay black pawns go wait
yeah it's chuck
could be bishop h2 it's probably just queen h4
i guess you just take and go here and just take
the queen um this is actually a really good run
now this could be the one i say that always but
you know i'm uh i'm a i'm a positive pessimist
b6 is probably winning but i'm not sure take
ray robson isn't competing for today uh he's
playing because he lost puzzle rush and to assert
dominance but he's not eligible for prizes today
and there should be chuck okay they'll be playing
for the world championships on the last day
um okay how do you do this there's some way
to try i guess just check check and take queen
is it is it h6 or f6 6 takes
so h6 or is it i think it's f6
it is okay just it takes or is it
all right 45 no wait king for g4 is a
draw i guess wait where's the bishop e
king for
bishop g4 is wrong it's king of three i don't know
this hour he caro and eloreza are
tied for fifteen feet in a minute chat
check i have 114 i have plenty of time
brutal could just be bishop two maybe and it takes
all right f3 chuck h4
gamble somehow although i
don't i just don't see it
okay
yeah that was wrong no time just no time just no
time there no time at all chad were they still
having a good time the first hour was won
by hikaru nakamura with 55 anderson won the
second one with 55 i believe and now we have the
following standings i think everybody wants to
see that let's jump into it first of all is he
corona with 53 alariza has 53 ammon hamilton
is tied with alexander costa the egg for
37 and they with quicker coming in with 36
i'm too loud i hate to see it man i could turn
down the mic a little bit but i should be good
maybe compared with the the vapor ones uh
it's not what you want but i don't wanna
i don't want to win i don't want to shout out
your eardrums yet how much time is left in
this hour uh 42 minutes we still have 42 minutes
raised streaming at the moment it's not eligible
because rey is infinitely better than all the
competitors combined so he'll be playing for the
he'll be eligible for the last day where
he's guaranteed to win eight thousand dollars
that's why the other days he won't
participate because he's just gonna
win eight thousand dollars on the last day so that
makes sense right does make sense all right cool
that's it 40 minutes ago let's play
some puzzle watch yourself chat
i've been feeling good looking good feeling fine
double time let's get some ratings ourselves
let's get the top okay off to a
good start let's take some stuff
okay okay uh let's take this one you should
just check and we take this note and king here
um i'm actually really confused
what this is okay that's not it
that was a really difficult one they almost
motivation daniel ditzki and andrew tang both quit
so they are out it's so playing puzzles
for so long chad is really gruesome
it really takes the life out of you so
i do get that also the hair in my mouth
so let's remove that one real quick here we
got a nice suffocator check check and a queen
i thought this was made of a winning
queen instead also pretty good um
that seems like the most logical conclusion
this one seems pretty good i think
we're just going to win a queen
i'm a bit slower than all the other gm's yet i
apologize for that but you know i'm gonna have
to work with today we're gonna have to work
with it bishop here no we just take this what
is undefended i can go knight here and that's
the one here we just take and we start running
that is pretty good i think it's the bishop here
and there we go for a mate all right we're are
doing fine chats we are doing fine what is this
one though is it's just i think it's queen here
or not you know oh it's queen check and then it's
rookie seven okay i could have been a lit a little
bit more aggressive with that but it is what
is check we take this take the rook um be dumpy
fairly easy fairly easy stuff
that we have going on right now
hikari is still first with alireza so we're
gonna see who's gonna be the winner at the end
that was not a mistake i refuse to
believe that there was a mistake yet
oh i should have taken the bishop what am i doing
what am i doing man okay one more
one more we can do this [ __ ]
yep robson is just a beast man he's
just he's just superior in every way
he's too good man he's just too good
you hate to see it actually you love to see
it all myself some solid chests being played
uh excuse me oh there we go i was sure
that why that one wasn't difficult for me
sometimes they're just a little bit more difficult
than you first anticipate i was gonna run here
this should be good enough for me we're just going
to grab this one and we have a pretty decent start
yet we have a pretty decent start let's let's keep
this up let's keep this up with the puzzle rush
check and is there something nice here no
this was satisfied this is a queen trap
pretty known one uh if you didn't
know it you'll know it by now
i think it's queen check here bomb pins no i was
i was just trying to show you guys it was being
pinned i'm being trolled and that is tragic
okay i knew that wasn't the move chad i'm oh
i'm trolling i'm actually trolling i i just
wanted to drag it so you guys could see
i couldn't put it there i didn't
put it on another thing okay
whatever chad you can't believe
me you don't have to all right
sorry i got loud man you hate to see it you'd love
to see this though i think we're doing pretty well
pretty pretty well uh i think i need to run
here can i take this one of the darnia he quit
stop streaming um
i think i just queen here and look at that
speed of a demon chat the speed of a
demon do we go rook here do we go rookie
what's the other rook let's see it 27 i still have
two and a half minutes left yet i'm too impatient
i know you guys want to see some other streamers
one of those streamers is for instance alarisa
so has have a look at him really
soon let's look at the top boards
it's under me you can see that um yeah there
are a lot of different puzzles you can do
corruption is just a beast the beast of the
east make sure to follow everyone that you
see on twitch ladies and gentlemen the chess
scene is growing and i want to grow with you
guys for those who don't know me let me introduce
myself again my name is bigfoot at least what they
call me because i got big feet um i'm streamer as
well but more important i'm the chess.com esport
producer for europe we produce all these kind
of things tomorrow i won't be there i mean i
will be there i'll be producing but it will be
grandmaster maurice ashley joining the fray um
so that's gonna be really good as well we still
have 35 minutes of puzzle rush left so let's have
a look at alireza and let's see if he can clinch
yet another victory let's have a little peek
26.
i don't know what is wrong with me
i guess it his takes no no
um
wait i didn't see him in kimchi
i
oh my god i have thousand chicks here um knight g4
rp7
checking king g8 um i have to go rook g3 i believe
okay queen is 6 on rookie 5 knight
g6 i think i have to take this guy
knight g5 and bishop f4 shall be six on rookie two
on bishop d4 i think i have to go here oh god um
okay this one i think i'll go here
you can get five rookies
i think it's f6 though
g5 h3
we should be for check or queen a2 we
should be four king b1 i don't see it
and there is knight c6 but that's just insane
i mean are you kidding me knight c6
and g6 what i have g i have g6 on h6
i'll take this guy
okay i have to take
um a4 takes c4 um um
let's go for the mates i guess now queen of seven
oh my god
what an absolute chad although it's not the best
i mean he did say holy but you know oh we'll grind
him for it i'll slap him on the fingers afterwards
what a beast man let's have a quick look at
the karu and see how it reacts to that news
go here
um
i have 46 with 209 i mean come on i've got 46 with
209 i really should not be be able to mess this
up i guess just here and here okay focus takes
queen h5 is no good bishop what is this puzzle
queen h5927 bishop f4 maybe
yeah i don't even know what that
puzzle is olly rosa had 54 okay
i mean i don't think anyone's gonna get over
55 so it's probably gonna be a tie for uh for
the highest score i think because i think at
this point everyone's a little bit tired so
it's unlikely that we're going to see a new
high score unless like one of us just goes
get them to get insane luck with the
mid-40s puzzles so i guess that's the upside
i guess just this okay yes just make a draw okay
that's gotta be or wait no it's not uh
okay
like
i guess i keep going in this
puzzle russia not a good one
alright has 43 again he's been
doing uh extremely well uh
as we let's quickly jump into
iron rose and who put up a beanie
who's in has danny gonna win anything have
a look how to do oh i'm trapping the rook
weird position
because i'm winning the bishop but how wait
a minute ah okay it might be eight ideas
it might just be f4 actually ah it wasn't f4
everyone uh let me quickly show the leaderboards
i'm sure a lot of you want to see the hour free
leader board it's eloresia ferozia coming in first
with 54 at the moment with only 26 minutes
left igor nakamura is second on 53 alexander
kostinic 46 really high as well the chess queen
on amazon 41 quicker 41 and so on the list goes
yeah it's a slow puzzling with uh i'm rose
let's jump back into it and see how it's doing
does this move
i mean both moves should be winning
i guess i'll avoid queen va check
i don't have to do this
knight knight g6 looks nice
okay so i need to be accurate
is that not meat king here here here and
then mate and if here what am i missing
why is g6 not mating
oh king h3 oh so i had to play i had
to play rogue shoe first and then
and then h5 and then the king goes back
okay hey it's toggy what's up tagi
if you're just joining you are
two and a half hours late almost kind of
um oh wait there's not too much time left
so it's a three-hour long session of puzzle
rush uh it's been a lot of puzzle solving
and puzzle non-solving and check this one oh
yeah so i i didn't want to play this because 95
i guess i guess the g pawn can then
move not studied any openings yet
now i am wondering if i should study
a single opening in great depth or try
to get the main ideas of different
openings what would you recommend
if you haven't studied any openings yet
try and nail down a repertoire first
so one opening against e4 one opening against d4
and then uh something for white and
something for white you can can maybe uh
learn deeply because it depends what black does i
call i'm rose enough we can't give out free advice
here chad and let it happen nice i'm the host and
producer of today you don't see me that much you
know i just scroll through live looking a little
bit doing my thing i'll let these streamers do the
work for me that's how you deal with chat and i
just bring you the top 10 score that's what i do
chad of the score at the moment alireza is still
with 54 points elorisa ferruja if i pronounced
it correctly i think i did see corona camaro is
still on 53. alexandra custody ended on 46. and
actually let's have a quick look at anna kremling
on 34 right now and maybe she can get a little
bit higher let's show her some love everyone
let's see how she is doing oh maybe it's hannah
let we push
queen check we take this
okay that one we've done before
that one i did remember actually
can we go there is that gonna be checkmate
let's see yeah that's right i agree i agree
there you go bishop there just
gonna stop everything aren't you
you are just gonna stop
everything i don't like that
why is my why is this puzzle stopping my my
ideas oh i guess i got there no you can't stop
it nothing can stop us let's go night check
what oh is there some checkmate sort of thing
can we take with the queen
it's gonna go night and takes
check night can i take there is that crazy
ah we're doing it hey it worked oh wait this
is a check that is with check okay you know
what i thought it was something crazy like
that okay anna roll next rule do not do it
do not do it um do not go for crazy moves
queen takes we take here
night there
30 seconds 30 seconds 30 we have to
interrupt your schedule problem for a
news report ladies and gentlemen we have ikoro
nakamura 54. he did get him he did get there
what a beast uh with irisa let's see if otherwise
i heard about the news and how he responds to it
who got 54 okay who cares
i wanna live faster
is
come on with 19 minutes left everyone 19 minutes
getting a bit left now i don't like that
myself
46 125 left that's a great start 47 tonight three
no that's wrong yeah the the the
that last one's just too hard
that's disgusting last like four last three
to four so let's try to put up a 57 if i can
he still hasn't won at all so it's worth it all i
need is 56 how hard can it really be what is this
how hard it gets let's quickly jump to the
overall leader portrait this is not our three
this is the overall leader board he carl and ali
raza have tied 55 and down here this key quit
so he's not going to jump in and andrew
tang also going to quit so that's not
going to work the overall little board icaru
and erisa oh 55 um if it comes to a tie
they split some money that's how this
chat that is how it is so um let's jump
back to alaris actually he's down 34 with three
minutes left let's see if he can make the cut
why he played king g3 though
foreign
tybrick is in the overall score they split
the money that's correct they split the money
oh god damn it yeah what is going on here
knight c1 of course knight c1
uh
11k followers now has 14k followers is that
jumping up quite a bit this guy is going there
how should i make both queen like
oh god this is not fair
i mean possible again oh come on queen
b5
i mean knight c4 97 that's
crazy um quincy for gaining four
i like queen g for guinea
for because i like this more
that's the check queen f5 rocket shade
you get six working g6 balls are possible
queen five doesn't work okay um king g6 is
very nice move i like this move but they don't
i didn't sign up for this like this is just
suddenly it got very tense
i thought it's a chill tournament look at stew
um rp7
we need seven rook g7 who knows
like who knows what is the move here
that's crazy only got 46.
what a noob chad what a new
uh was actually on 48th with only two
mistakes let's see how he's doing 49 now
i'm at 50. i have two wrong but i'm at 50. like
this should be doable it's quenching is it h6
okay what is this black pond's going up the
board so this is white to plan when wait a second
good block to plane win okay is it two
good it's free it needs two more chips okay
t6 is no good rook h6 is no good rook h6 for
cage six rook h6 rook h6 d6 just 39 seconds
could just be rook d3
wow okay one more wow he needs one more um
he needs one more to clinch the victory five
rook f1 second time oh man oh man press
oh man so close man what is the solution
okay last two
i'm doing better though i know i'm doing better
i'm close to cracking it oh whoops that was oh
[ __ ] that was just a massive okay i gotta start
over start or start over start over so close man
all right everyone let's have a quick look at the
leaderboards the caro and alireza still at 54.
and on place number eight we see anna kremling
and number nine we see anna maya so it's gonna
be the battle of the anna's who is going to be
over each other there's a wild little thing going
on right there so let's get some love to anna
let's jump over to her with the final 10 minutes
don't worry we'll keep you updated with alireza
and kiko but let's show some love to anime
some profound commentary going on right now chad
i'll do it for her don't worry
no okay there it is there it is
going well you got four minutes left why
are you going so fast was the win right ah
screw this only let's jump over to i want hamilton
from the chess boss oh my god the knight guards it
oh that was really quick it didn't even
count me down or something that was weird
sorry we need to make a quick switch and
loriza51
oh my god and back to a mom where am
i made in one let's get those in there
uh hello
here this virtue one here
where's the good music here we have some good news
here what's my records on survival's 59 on five
minutes it's 38 i believe is my records 30. anyway
chad welcome back we only have six minutes left of
this uh round and one of the prizes that i wanted
to mention real quick is that you could also win
well streamers could win the best clip which is
a twitter poll so if you look at the twitch set
right now real close hope you guys are ready
we're going to spam it you can still vote the
poll will be open for another two hours
make sure to vote for your favorite streamer
and see which clip is the best one like i said my
name is bigfoot um pleasure to be producing to be
working with you all hope you guys are still
having a lot of fun ten thousand of you are
still on twitch love you in chess tv on youtube we
don't forget about you as well and facebook who's
on facebook anymore all right grandma ross thank
you for watching you know this is grab my friendly
content i'm just saying chad we could have some
grammar content here um we're in the final moments
let's show the leaderboard one more time and then
we're going to go to the top streamers the carl
and anariza still on 54. let's flash real quick
who is closer we have uh hikaru just started new
and erisa oh 44 with two and a half minutes left
maybe this is the one chat see what he can bring
uh for the question ray robson only participates
in the last six stream two minutes like what
um we need two rupees one rook d1 e3
queen of three no what are smoking oh my god this
is just insanely hard this is something insane 283
queenie too bishop divorced one i have this
feeling now oh my god these are just insane
i have to take this bishop here okay rook g2
king h5 i don't see it i just don't see it
i just don't see it that's the problem i just
it's just insane i mean this is just insane
sometimes you don't see it these
are just impossible to solve
like hey baby gm just described for
you look only three minutes left chad
uh let's see how he car was doing he is on 36.
okay do you need to move
um
what
it's just a draw some maybe you just
make a draw i don't understand this
or do you have queen d3 wait no are you 23 yeah
that would have been the end of the
road for me i this one i don't even
know what it could be other than checking
maybe double i don't even know i can take
okay a few questions in chat i see mvl's name at
the start is he taking part that was a dummy name
mvl is taking part just today i think it will
be for day three and days uh there's nine i'm
going to get about 149. i know it's confirmed
for day five i'm not sure for day three some
great i mean yeah it's 95. i can try one more
but there's no way there's only two minutes left
let's just let's just see how far i can get in
these next two minutes i i assume this doesn't
count although does it since it started before
uh to start before does this count does it
does it does it count if like if it starts
before or not good question it does count
okay so last one okay last one last one try to
clutch it up look at that louisa no they're both
having a little bit of it going um we only
have one minute left ladies and gentlemen
jump back to the regular seasons let's
jump back to us how's everyone doing
for everyone event by my own that's the
name thank you very much um let's look
at the format look at the formats we don't care
about the format we care about the leaderboards
our free leaderboards the car nakamura is
still the number one tied with elleriza
they both win they're also both for the overall
leaderboards really well so we're going to look
at that one real quick it's going to count only
have a few seconds left chat so it will not change
i'm still in the free streak uh
alexander costanique also got
stuck at 46 i'm on hamilton 44. so on and
so on so a very strong field and we are
officially done right now uh you're going to give
us a few minutes to see who is the overall leader
but i would like to remind you that you can uh you
can cast a vote on the poll it's still open for
two hours make sure that you clip at least you're
not gonna clip you're gonna vote who you think is
the best clip i'm gonna have a look a better there
better be a clip of me in there you know you're
gonna be a clip of me okay no it's not unlucky
i hate to see it man i hate to see it anyway
um we are done right now daniel left after hour
two because he didn't think he could make it
anymore let's have a quick final look in the chess
bros with some music while we tally up this course
way too many moves
[ __ ] you know what am i supposed to
do literally brutal so many ways to win
yeah this is definitely not the run
okay the final one still counts and i
have ellie razer at 39 and we have hikaru
at 39 as well they're both 39 they're both of
two and a half minutes this is actually really
exciting chad yeah this is the final run if the
run started before the end of this end of the time
it would count we're gonna see if this is
going to work on the razer 43 against 42.
cara also has 43 now they both have two and a half
minutes left is just bad did you draw the phone
okay b6 c7 takes p6
oh my god it's important icarus on 45
zero zero mistakes 46. that's crazy
i just go here i don't care um
i like to be small for this bad
it's just very hard what happened yeah
i guess he didn't make it he didn't make
it uh let's quickly jump to hikaru who's
on his final run goes on wait what's this
he takes okay and takes oh man that burns so
much time off my clock that's so unbelievable
um there should be he needs to get seven right in
the middle of time no time now this there's some
trick with the queen check but it's a you have to
check on the right square and i don't know which
it's this check and it's this check and it's this
check okay good um is it this please be rookie too
you just need six rights he just needs
five correct ones in 30 seconds oh gosh
my man gg i can't do it what about this is too
much it's too much there we go just too much
yeah there we go razer is in chat here what's up
my man welcome how are you doing uh one second uh
so we're going to tell you this course who's
going to be the final the final victor ladies
and gentlemen uh is here as well the cool kids who
listen man no no hold up hold up i'm mad at you
first of all i interview you for the bullet open
championship you have a camera that looks like
you're being held hostage in a basement and
when you're streaming suddenly it looks like
you have like a ten thousand dollar camera
all right what's up with that second of all
at tata still just i'm gonna be attached hugest
as well don't worry about that i'll be at that
steel chairs i'll be producing i'm giving you
my number and we never had dinner all right
so i know you have to stream you did but related
to him chad i have some questions for
him he's gonna go over to me anyway um
um all right chad we're gonna tally up the
scores and it should be that this is the
overall leader board i'm gonna get confirmation
on that real quick ikarna kamara and alireza
will split the money when it comes to the
overall winners and they both take their fair
share in the hourly so congrats to them uh
icarl won in the first hour ali raza won in
the second hour they tied in the third hour
and they tied overall so if i am correct they
both get 875 dollars but i'm gonna get
there some confirmation on that soon so
yeah they are quite amazing though
they're not as good as ray robson
he is beyond better than everyone else so i'm just
saying that's the way it is um make sure to go to
twitter chat bigfoot once a date i date him it's
kind of it's kind of cute [ __ ] it's kind of cute
um thanks we're right behind him yeah yep what
a beast definitely a beast daniel only one down
um for tomorrow chat for tomorrow we'll have
survival mode with the host the one and only
maurice ashley grand masterminds ashley will be
there uh for the survival mode let's explain the
one real quick we're gonna pair up in teams of
two and they're going to try to get the highest
possible survivor score with the prizes as well
great show thank you everyone hope you guys enjoy
who won today aloriza and hikaru were the big
winners on day three puzzle battle 16 uh invited
streamers um hold on i'm getting a confirmation
that lorisa wants to have an interview so let's
have an interview with alariza real quick uh i'm
gonna go for a quick commercial break just real
quick chat i'm gonna set things up and then let's
have uh some uh some talk with the man himself
see you guys in just a bit guys uh stay
here we're gonna have a talk about a
reason
four three right welcome everyone uh we are back
somebody's music i think
oh okay um sorry can you repeat the question
yes yes
yeah it's very tough i i started i think i played
only for two and like two hour and ten minutes so
i didn't play the whole three hours that helped a
bit a little bit i think and uh but yeah two hours
and non-stop to solve tactics just you can
lose your mind simply i think i was lucky
i got some good records so that was motivation
to keep going uh very soon so yeah i was lucky
yeah sometimes you get the lucky puzzles uh
that is true yeah some other questions for you
already when i interviewed you for the bullet
open championship it looks like you were hell
being held hostage in a room with like a small
camera and it was really dark and now a few days
later you have an amazing webcam an amazing
quality you're going back on the stream grind
yeah we worked a little bit on
in this technical things because
yeah this speed championship was just a very bad
memory like i lost our i lost my power during the
game against photosafe so now it's all good yes
we are back for the streaming me and my brother
mostly my brother do the things but i am always
here in the channel i will uh i will play a lot of
games um so yeah amazing man dude i want to thank
you for coming here uh one final question alireza
you'll be in vaikonzi uh i'll be in vikanze great
we're finally gonna have to dinner yes we should
have that dinner one year i currently see one
year ago okay finally one we should go do that yes
and you're buying by the way i'm just saying we
should wait for a year that's a long way i raised
it thank you so much and thank you you have to go
uh again make sure to follow chat twitch.dv says
parusia he's been getting like 3k followers
already during the stream so it's it's mad you
talented and uh keep it going man thank you very
much thank you very much see you see you mackenzie
see if i can say all right then
ladies and gentlemen that was alireza
the absolute beast from the east uh
as we uh as we previously mentioned
as we previously mentioned he blitzed it
pretty well he did awesome he did amazing
uh sorry for the the mic issues at the start
it's a little bit different from getting someone
that's already streaming into a stream that's
a different stream you get what i'm saying um
but you guys have been amazing congratulations to
ricardo and elisa for clinching the spot i don't
know exactly how much they made question mark
um but i think it was 8.75 per really matter
let's look at tomorrow that's the most important
part survival month with grand master maurice
ashley he will be there uh he will be there in
teams of two the players who will find out they'll
play matchmaking you know will be glorified cupids
will make the streamers go into paris they'll play
survival mode and what maurice actually casting it
it's up to that now what are the prizes for those
i'm glad you asked yet best overall score gets
a thousand second best overall score 500 best in
first hour second hour third hour we'll have the
best clip and we'll have the longest attempt those
in who've been doing it for the longest minutes
which is going to be interesting all together
pressured in stream on a date listen man all
right i've got to abuse my power somehow all right
he didn't he did it i'm still mad at him for last
year i'm telling you i'm telling you i was waiting
he's like a very nice kid you know he's being
really good and then he doesn't take the into you
unbelievable man unbelievable anyway chad um
you've been amazing i'm sorry for the technical
difficulties that's up to me but you know we're
going to do better tomorrow because we will be
back tomorrow jammer same time uh we'll be with
maurice ashley and congratulations to the winners
alireza and ikaro for kin lynching the thing uh
i think we're gonna rate by raid aderaza question
mark no i do not we're going to rate both tests as
i said the same things you know they both have the
same qualities one could say chad thanks so much
for being here i really appreciate it on chess tv
on everywhere you guys are amazing each and
every one of you congratulations to everyone
who participated tomorrow we'll be back with a
lot more puzzle action so stay tuned and final
reminder go to twitter if someone in the twitch
chat and justify chat can distribute that link
the poll will still be open for two hours
who had the best clip that one also gets 750
dollars for acting crazy on stream that's not too
bad yet my name is bigfoot make sure to follow me
as well twitch.tv bigfoot 24 hour stream this
sunday and we will see you in the next stream
thank you guys so much for being here and
i'll see you all tomorrow take care everyone
so